estamos viviendo momentos nunca pensados
no imaginados ciertamente el curso de
los acontecimientos no nos ha permitido
prever ni anticiparnos nuestro mejor
recurso ha sido adaptarnos y aprender de
las circunstancias nos enfrentamos a una
nueva forma de vivir pues lo que estamos
viviendo marcará un antes y un después
en nuestra vida y en las futuras
generaciones hemos tenido tiempo de
conectarnos internamente y es por esto
que quiero compartir con ustedes una
experiencia compitiendo en un triatlón
que ha venido a mi mente recurrentemente
en esta época y me ha sido útil para
renovar mi optimismo y calmar la
ansiedad
en octubre del 2019
llegué a kentucky a participar en
ironman número 13
estaba emocionada y estresada como
siempre el estrés y la adrenalina son
ingredientes permanentes y necesarios
antes de una competencia más aún cuando
ésta representa recorrer una distancia
tan larga 226 kilómetros y además tener
objetivos ambiciosos me había propuesto
clasificar al campeonato mundial y en
principio el entrenamiento que había
hecho aumentaba mis probabilidades la
preparación fue muy específica una
estrategia diseñada en conjunto con
entrenador basada en mi realidad
personal en el hecho de que no dispongo
de todo el tiempo que quisiera para
entrenar debido a que siempre hay otras
responsabilidades obligaciones viajes y
actividades que interrumpen y
planificación entonces la estrategia
consistía en trabajar directamente y en
persona con uno de los entrenadores
asistentes que trabaja con mi entrenador
las dos semanas anteriores a la semana
de la carrera
el viajó a quito a guiarme y entrenar
conmigo
el objetivo era subir mi nivel mi
resistencia y mi velocidad para esto
entrene dos o tres sesiones al día
sumando entre 25 y 30 horas de
entrenamiento a la semana para tener una
idea mi semana normal está entre las 12
y 16 horas
tenía confianza en mi preparación y me
sentía fuerte el día anterior de la
carrera se confirmó que cancelaban la
natación a causa de una alga venenosa la
natación consistía en nadar 3800 metros
en aguas abiertas
era la primera vez que iba a competir en
un triatlón sin natación no era lo ideal
y supongo en algún momento me tenía que
tocar
él iba se estaba enfriando la noche
anterior a la carrera pude descansar
algo no muy usual antes de una
competencia ahí comprobé que gran parte
de la ansiedad y el estrés me lo
ocasiona la natación que es la
disciplina que menos domina en la que me
siento menos cómoda
el día de la carrera estaba frío y en el
segmento de ciclismo sí sentí la
diferencia de no haber nadado antes me
costó mucho calentarme y el clima
tampoco ayudada sentía que no fluía en
la bicicleta y estaba como trabada
finalmente terminé esos 180 kilómetros
con bastante desnivel y poca energía y
esperaba sacar lo mejor de mí para el
atletismo empecé a correr y después de
cerca del kilómetro 2 empezó un dolor de
espalda y cadera y me dije no puede ser
lo que me faltaba
se me llenaron los ojos de lágrimas y me
dieron ganas de llorar porque me di
cuenta que el dolor no me permitía
correr al ritmo por el que me había
preparado
y en ese momento inicie una profunda
conversación conmigo misma
un diálogo que iba más o menos así
me duele la espalda no me siento bien
tengo que bajar el ritmo porque que me
está pasando he entrenado también no es
justo hice todo lo que tenía que haber
hecho no falle en nada mi entrenamiento
mi hidratación y nutrición hasta logré
dormir bien anoche y si me sigue
doliendo y si tengo que parar y si se
pone peor y no puedo terminar no tengo
que terminar así sé arrastrándome como
sea con ese diálogo interno me di cuenta
de que no iba a encontrar ninguna de
esas respuestas y que era momento de
tomar decisiones
tuve que actualizar mis objetivos y
replantearnos
aterrizar mi ambición de subir al podio
y clasificar al campeonato mundial y
conformarme con terminar
enfocarme en terminar y poner toda mi
energía y esfuerzo en avanzar paso a
paso con el único fin de cruzar esa meta
en el tiempo y en el estado que sea
cuidarme y preocuparme solamente en
avanzar en poner un pie frente al otro
sin parar
en vista de que todo estaba re planteado
tome otra decisión tal vez la más
compleja
en vista de que ya no importaba el
tiempo ni la posición ni el ritmo no iba
a volver a ver el reloj me dije no voy a
regresar a ver el reloj hasta que cruce
esa meta
no me voy a estresar por el ritmo al que
estoy corriendo tan distante del
esperado
ni tampoco me interesa el tiempo ni los
kilómetros que llevo recorriendo
tengo que terminar esta carrera eso es
lo más importante ahora eso es lo único
importante ahora
con esas dos determinaciones y nuevos
acuerdos seguir corriendo conectándome
con mi cuerpo pidiéndole que me diera lo
que pudiera sin presionar el dolor fue
desapareciendo y seguí corriendo
concentrada en avanzar hidratándome y
comiendo según lo planificado cuidando
mi postura y mirando al frente sin
volver a ver al reloj
cerca de 38 kilómetros después cruce esa
meta soñada y miré el reloj nuevamente
según el acuerdo que había hecho conmigo
misma y me llevé la gran sorpresa de que
había corrido en la maratón más rápida
de mi vida
minutos después confirmaba que estaba
tercera en mi categoría al día siguiente
me subí a el podio y obtuve mi cupo para
acá para participar en el campeonato
mundial de ironman en kona
porque les cuento todo esto
cada una de mis carreras y experiencias
en el triatlón se han convertido en
metáforas que han sido útiles en mi vida
en el momento menos pensado
y el recuerdo de esta historia en
particular ha sido de gran utilidad al
enfrentar estos momentos tan complicados
e inciertos
cuando todos nuestros planes han sido
pospuesto sin fecha donde la
incertidumbre y la indefinición expande
cada día
en momentos cuando nos vemos amenazados
y palpamos la necesidad de ser
responsables no sólo de nuestra salud
sino de la de los demás mi mente viaja a
ese momento de duda en competencia
cuando todo lo que había planificado lo
tuve que replantear donde mi herramienta
principal para lograr mi meta dejó de
ser me útil y lo tuve que descartar y
liberarme de él para poder cumplir con
mi nuevo objetivo
en estos momentos cuando lo que no
habíamos contemplado se nos presenta
recuerdo ese momento en que en tokio y
busco la metáfora que puedo adaptar a lo
que ahora estamos viviendo
primero
el que la capacidad de movernos se haya
visto reducida no debe evitar que
sigamos moviéndonos
no debemos detenernos dejemos de mirar
el reloj aprovechemos el tiempo para
reinventarnos y descubrir algo nuevo en
nosotros el tiempo ha cobrado otra
dimensión podemos dejar de vivir en
horas o días y vivir en actividades en
aprendizajes conversaciones lecturas y
encuentros con nosotros mismos
segundo no perdamos el optimismo
avancemos con la confianza de que el
resultado nos puede sorprender y podemos
cruzar tantas metas como nos fijemos y
al final de muchas conquistas los
resultados nos pueden dar increíbles
sorpresas y premiamos con el genuino
reconocimiento a nuestro esfuerzo
dedicación y auténtica voluntad de salir
adelante gracias